I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning and as I said I am a fan of
all three of you for people that have
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why
wow
um I mean I think we all should be
watching the wire for every reason
though has nothing to do with me but
just watch the wire and you'll be happy
thank you
and they can watch the wire for me too
and I'll just pretend that yeah
I asked Julia Roberts the same question
and she said Pulp Fiction
that's amazing you know
um uh Michael is that your answer it's
just gonna stick with the wire sure yeah
it's good oh yeah okay next up
um so one of the things when you guys
were making season three you couldn't
have known how real the world would like
the the the way it crosses over almost
with the real world can you sort of talk
about that aspect that it's a it's a
little too close for home
yeah I mean I think it's unequivocally
heartbreaking I think it's it's uh it's
something that we certainly didn't
intend we wrote the idea for the show
about three years ago
um I like to put a small homage to all
of Tom Clancy's books or movies in the
series in this series or this season we
had decided to make it Hunt for Red
October so that's how we settled on
Russia instead of a nuclear submarine we
thought what it would it be like to have
the main uh threat be Intel from a man
so you're looking for one man not a
submarine and so we had all these fun
things to play with and we thought we
were making a Larger than Life season of
Television that was so far beyond the
imagination uh that you'd have a really
good time through this Thrill Ride and
then to see in real life not only is it
um uh uh not beyond the imagination but
it's it's horrific tenfold you know I
think what's going on in real life is
worse than anything we could have put in
the show and and with that that we take
that all very seriously for all three of
you I love learning about like the
behind the scenes of the making of a
show and I'm so curious which for each
of you
um which shot of the seasons you've been
involved with for Jack Ryan uh ended up
being the hardest and why I'll go first
being thrown out of a Blackhawk uh by a
Navy SEAL was definitely the hardest and
most impressed I've ever been with
myself ever
um though I should probably be scared of
my stupidity basically what happened
that morning was
um two stunt guys had gone through each
five or six takes of that and then as we
were flying out to the next scene in
that Blackhawk one of the Navy's deals
said it would have been way cooler if
you did it and I said well how would
that look and he said it would look like
me unbuckling your seatbelt right now
and throwing you out of this helicopter
and he did and it's to me that was the
hardest scariest and you can see on my
face I was definitely very scared that
was the hardest thing I've done in the
show I have a hand-to-hand combat with a
knife
um in Moscow uh this season that was the
hardest for me it was the most was fun
we did all kinds of different takes we
changed choreography all kinds of stuff
and then to actually throw him down
um flights of stairs uh and actually
um actually see it happen uh was
thrilling
um so that was the hardest but also one
of the most satisfying
and for me it would have to be it's
nothing to do with action it was being
on the Danube River under a bridge
with this guy
who rewrote the entire scene uh
an hour before we were filming and it's
a walk and talk and in a wind tunnel on
the Daniel River and it was guys with a
screen above of one foot above my head
like this walking One Foot In Front of
Me and trying to just trying to get
through the scene and him like no you
got it you got it it's fine it's come on
we got we got this guy that's over and
over and over again and the third part
first and the second part third and then
it's completely rearranged the entire
scene I was like oh yeah I can do that
and I just wanted to die and Mike
prepares Mike's you should see his
scripts the preparation and all of the
notes and the history behind it and then
he comes to set just prepared and he has
time to do so because he has three
breakfasts
and then I guess he got to sit and they
said no we're not gonna do it like that
but uh so I know that probably was
difficult it haven't it happened quite
often with this guy but I that that
being said
[Music]
um
he works is that John works his ass off
and wants everything to be perfect and
so you know as pissed as you are when
you get it you know it's gonna be better
so you're like all right I'll do it but
it messes with my flow I actually wanted
to ask you that John obviously you're a
very talented writer director
um and it seems like you're tweaking
dialogue you know but did you at any
point did you think about directing
episodes or is it almost that's just too
much no I never thought about directing
the episodes and again we have
incredible writers it's really about
um you know as heady as it sounds the
show or whatever you're working on at
some point always takes a life of its
own and sort of will tell you what it
wants to be and what it can and can't be
and so things that you wrote you know
five months ago as little changes have
been happening throughout the show you
realize that you have to implement
things that you you did in other scenes
and so the show just feels like it can
make small changes that's the only thing
I would ever uh help with we had an
incredible producing team and great
writer so it was never just me doing it
it was more about
um I felt you know because uh I I take
the show really seriously I just wanted
to make sure that it was the best that
it could be I never changed Wendell's
lines though just his I wonder what that
says
we are shooting Eight Episodes at a time
and cross-boarding the whole thing so
John's right like one thing changes here
and you don't realize it but it's gonna
affect something that you have to shoot
two weeks later in a completely
different option you just feel bad about
everything you said about me I did yeah
that's a little hard all right what do
you actually think would surprise fans
of Jack Ryan to learn about the actual
making of the show behind the scenes I
think that it's so much fun I mean that
I I I'm not kidding when I say I think
the only other time I laughed this hard
on set was on The Office I think that
this show as intense as it looks we have
such a good time together because we
genuinely love each other and have
developed real friendships not just uh
you know work acquaintances and so that
I think that to me that's the most
surprising thing that when you see the
show people say like how did you get
through it and the truth is we had a
blast doing it together I also love to
travel and uh they they always make fun
of me because I will always find
something a unique experience in
different countries uh you know whether
it's a Seaside midnight
uh Seafood
Chef who prepares uh this wonderful meal
for me and essoia Morocco or the
Budapest jazz club where I would go and
hang out with this late night uh jazz
band and sit in a couple of times
meanwhile I had dominoes and Netflix
because
that's that's what uh
um I really take advantage of the
different places we go to to find these
unique little places to go and unique
things to do and we've had we've had
some great we have some great times
discovering those yeah I'm just looking
at window in amazement because John
nicknamed him wizard because he would
just he's not kidding he would disappear
we would be out he would disappear and
then the next day would show up at work
I'm like what'd you get into last night
well it's crazy because I was you know I
left you guys and then I went walking
down this alley and there was this door
and I said oh I should probably go in
that door and I went in the door and
then there was this Wizard and The
Wizard took me on a boat so there I was
in the middle of the ocean and I'm
eating this crazy food that I've never
had him he's like well what would you
guys do we're like uh watch TV it's like
he would just yeah and it was it was
often it wasn't just once or twice it's
he's the wizard man on that note I'm
gonna have to stop I'm just gonna say um
I really no I really want to thank you
for your work and um for making an
entertaining show and I wish you guys
nothing but the best thank you so much
thanks for always being supportive